from tomorrow our advice will be that
all household contacts of any confirmed
covert case should isolate for 10 days
regardless of their vaccination status
and even if they initially get a
negative pcr test i know that this is
not easy and
we will obviously keep it under review
we will also ensure careful exemptions
for critical services but we believe
this to be essential at this moment to
help slow transmission
non-household contacts should continue
to isolate pending a pcr result if that
is negative they can leave isolation at
that point as long as they are double
vaccinated
and secondly i want to refer to the
advice the public health scotland
made public late yesterday afternoon
that people should think about deferring
work christmas parties
now this is not easy advice to give or
to hear but it is incumbent on public
health experts to set out very clearly
and frankly the risks we face and it's
incumbent on me and government to pay
attention to that advice there is a
significant risk with omicron and we are
already seeing the reality of it of
christmas parties or events with lots of
people becoming super spreaders and if
that happens lots of people get infected
and if these are work events as well as
the risk to individual health there is a
risk to the ability of the workplace to
operate as people have to isolate and
i've already cited the train
cancellations and the accident in
emergency unit in lanarkshire as
examples and illustrations of that
so the public health advice which i have
no alternative but to agree with given
the evidence of risk
that i
know about and have now shared with you
is that we should all think a bit more
carefully about unnecessary contacts
especially in crowded places just now
and that it would be sensible to defer
work christmas parties now i know this
has a big impact on businesses which is
why we are considering and pressing the
uk government on financial support
but once again we face a situation that
frankly has no easy options we know that
any additional protective measures will
cause social and economic harms
especially after almost two years of
this pandemic but we also know from past
experience that early action is often
needed when dealing with this virus in
fact acting early is often the best way
of acting proportionately so we can't
rule out further measures and i'm afraid
we can't avoid the advice that i have
shared with you today